a matter of preference right okay so it
is gonna be Tara all right Matt the
Torah the Torah training has really paid
off a frisson chance absolute this
tournament I mean he's killed his demon
character right he's been killing my as
well after as well he had to kill at
least uh I think it was like three of
them just to make it the topic oh well
actually one of those was in top eight
here it was suicide so
pretty small stage here it has been
enhanced prior due to one of the old
patches but I small you would just get
bringing out my IV with it the first ten
seconds oh my guarantee knock down
pressure right here here we go hey just
wake up to a I like the decision you
know he's like I'm not gonna let you run
your game on me right what that does is
it establishes the thought in the Curris
head that he may just are present
buttons autumn rolling nice block 1a
there
this is so close right now [ __ ] Chang oh
what a duck you know they screw a first
blood in the quarters last few matches
his ducks under throws had been not
really high in percentage right you know
I don't usually expect to stop but
killing guy kind of when I'd see killing
I think more of like a mix-up kind of
player almost like an ex type of guy
right but the Qura he's so defensive
I mean that might be something to think
about if that's the case you know maybe
let's look just the way to play Aquila K
is also effective refer to his style is
just so different for what I've seen and
it's not surprised to see how effective
it is Wow nice speaking of effective
Shem can hit him three times that he
died good defense will only nice so long
as my Hulu and gloomy right now back to
jelly but I mean that's that's exactly
what he wants right he wants the stance
transition as much as possible that's a
with one slap oh and chin towel how can
we happily take that free beater from
the car uh turning over the monument
mix-up right there okay that was a
really delayed throat X so let me pick
every bit counts with those thoughts
I've seen if you take it late least
you're still on your feet by the mid
right there not a lot of life to work
with right now so it's gonna be scary
for him to try and to switch stances cuz
he could just get with punished entire
oh no unfortunate timing so you forget
your advil at home
I don't know need that excedrin is
something by the way it's actually hard
to get towels on Japan probably a reason
yes I don't know controlled substances
and I already got up to the ledge right
now good life as well he's got a lot of
bar to work with too so I mean he can
make kind of anything happen at the
structured Oh
great stab for chilling now I've been
one step too much more after that that
should be a bunny sha I'm wrong I was
not sure her see is like a sixteen
framer or something right I don't know
the exact number on it but oh my god I
guess maybe hit a button I'm not sure Oh
unfortunately yeah he was that was a
mere force right there I feel like that
should have been his whip punished
instead calibers of cool mistress she's
dancing what can I say
jumps over that oh my god no the hit box
interactions they're making me feel some
kind of way right now and then little by
little chef Chan is taking away the
clothes ablates uses lows by doing all
those jumping moves yeah you know
there's been a lot less 1s than you
would normally see from a killer Claire
I feel like sole charge is gonna come
out doesn't have a lot of life to work
with so yields okay makes sense I think
it's a good use of a bar he could deep
it almost go for it again if you really
wanted to this is the last round
yeah oh he tried to charge for forecast
all that spin okay here we go plus
frames I think he thought the Six Day
was gonna ring out so he didn't want to
influence it too much allow it he didn't
want to allow from Chania where the rest
of what and best the ring out exactly
but it was just it wasn't actually as
close as he thought damn Oh stress yes
the stress when I was joking earlier
about the super zoom in game number two
I had to see the poor all my goodness I
definitely saw some pores there just now
pretty stoic though I think he
understood what happened he was like
okay you know sometimes these things are
just what what go down happens
oh we gotta stop her yeah oh my goodness
so she can cancel that in the card
obviously but one of the things that's
really important is to show that you'll
stop her from doing it because if you
can't let her switch too much otherwise
she gets into gloomy Kota what our
response to corrode try to get a GI to
stop Shan Shan's wake up line and they
said shin-chan just watched it happen
three be easy finish for him it's time
to run away with this oh great way to
start running away with the reserve so
much damage put him at the ledges well
nine so he backed up just to goad him
into doing something he needs a lot more
than that though and shin-chan is still
using those jumping buttons to stop the
curl for B but he uses good lows he's
just a fence you're worried about
whatever button he could press right now
at the Audigy I know full conversion off
it another visitor she gets anymore
after that I don't know it might be
dependent on what stands it transitions
to when it hits whatever the case may be
Shanshan is currently on set point right
now looking to take out the Korra not
two bars for 4k comes out can't punish
it but the Kura hasn't really I don't
know if it's just that Shin Chan's
playing really see even when he steps
and he gets in chendo if he hasn't
really been able to get big damage yeah
that's actually a really strong point
right that's a watershed for him to get
big damage actually see comes out he
does have another par to work with and I
think honestly he's gonna need to use
everything he's got in his arsenal at
this point maybe a chance fighting so
seek right now
a lot block but unfortunately ya know I
think that was soul charge actually I'll
do water with one is well even if it was
so charged at least he's okay right now
fun right here it's good damage mix-up
City the flop of the minute God that
there's the low-cost and alive he needs
a lot more than this store and the
Demeter deficit is huge right now yeah
especially if he wins another round Chen
Chen is gonna get wait he's a gloomy
coda wow that was a huge oh no he's not
okay I thought for a second he was a
clue I saw the glow and it just lasted
longer than I thought that's why bad
watch your feet with punish okay
he's trying to finish the game right now
oh that's huge I think it's a smart
enough is enough it's gonna be close hey
one last wake up six a nice interrupts
with the QA he gets a throw of his own
it's gonna be a bit far away but it's
let's go but I can't still a mountain to
climb right he's got another game to
work with and shencheng
getting back into gloomy I almost feel
like he's doing that just to force the
Kuro to come close so he's in Kota right
okay nice no he's not in Kota okay so
charged with shin-chan
god I really need to count the
transitions for Tara because I've been
messing that up lifted right it's hard
to keep count when it's hyper psyche is
so chargeback that's gonna knock down I
think oh he tried to monument over
that's gonna get broken by the sole
charge unfortunately doesn't have a lot
of light to work with oh he's always
gonna get big damage during his soul
charge force block situation you're
trying to jump right there nice block of
the mid he gets away ah but finish it
off and Shanshan
staying in this tournament moving on
over the Qura but man what you know that
comeback was almost ridiculous